quién es la persona con la que más pasan
tiempo
resulta y resalta y un domingo de
bajaban estaba sentada en mi cama con el
teléfono por un lado
en la espera de alguna notificación
llamada amor o atención lo que sea que
se pudiera aparecer primero
me di cuenta que la persona con la que
más pasaba tiempo era la persona que
menos conocía
y acá entre nos así de caerme bien bien
pues no
ustedes se preguntarán andrea y pues tú
porque seguía ahí ok la verdad es que
era la única relación constante y a
largo plazo que yo había tenido
y estará conmigo misma
este domingo si llegó una notificación y
era la de mi promedio de tiempo en
pantalla que había subido un 20 por
ciento a 8 horas 15 minutos diarios
8 horas 15 minutos diarios en los que yo
ponían pausa mi vida para ponerle play a
la de los demás y ver cómo se supone que
ellos vivían la suya
pasamos tanto tiempo en las redes
sociales que olvidamos pasar tiempo con
las personas que más queremos y
deberíamos de querer como nosotros
mismos estamos tan conectados en
instagram twitter facebook que olvidamos
crear una conexión cuerpo y alma
olvidamos conocernos saber a dónde
queremos que apunte la chancla decidir a
dónde queremos llegar y qué necesitamos
para lograrlo
este domingo entendí que soy adicta
adicta a comparar mi vida con la de los
demás
adicta a una búsqueda constante de
aprobación y atención a través de likes
y comentarios adicta a crear esta imagen
en mi perfil de mujer fuerte feliz y
segura cuando por dentro estaba rota
triste e inestable
mi nombre es andrea
y soy adicta a las redes sociales
por esa notificación una patada de
vuelta a la realidad una hasta aquí pues
decidí emprender un viaje para el cual
necesitaba de toda la valentía que en
ese momento se los juro yo no tenía un
viaje para el cual estoy segura que el
95 por ciento de ustedes se la piensa
dos veces y vaya que yo me la pensamos
de 2
un viaje sedentario de 100 días sin
redes sociales
lo cierto es que ha aprendido muchísimo
sobre mí más que nada he tenido tiempo
para conocerme 8 horas 15 minutos al día
para ser exacta
y se me había olvidado la felicidad que
me traían los hábitos diarios para los
que yo había dejado hacer tiempo como
leer el correr volver las películas
malísimas de navidad que están en
netflix que todo mundo oye pero que a mí
me encantan y que decir del salir de la
rutina del típico fin de semana del
viernes llegar a tu casa por la tarde a
dormirte para despertarte a las 8 para
levantarte a las 9 porque a las 10
tienes que subir un safety ya las 11
tienes que subir otro pero con tus
amigos para que tus followers vean que
también te la estás pasando pero ni tú
te la compra y el sábado vuelve a ser el
mismo cuento
pero no más llega el tan despreciado
domingo y bastantes lo podemos resumir
en una lloraba y a dormir
han sido 79 días 18 horas 46 minutos y
unos tantos segundos en los que me he
sentido más viva más presente más feliz
y la vida dejo de ser aquello que pasa
mientras espero la próxima vibración de
mi teléfono y empezó a hacer eso que me
hace vibrar por fin entendí que mi valor
no se mide ni en la cantidad de likes ni
mucho menos en la cantidad de followers
sino en mi capacidad de amarme y de amar
a los demás de impactar en la gente de
mi alrededor de ser capaz de transmitir
paz con tan solo un abrazo de seguir
siendo amable incluso cuando alguien
esté siendo un total patán conmigo de
entender que este mundo se viene a dar
mucho antes que a recibir
pero claro que no todo fue color de rosa
alegrías aprendizajes cosas buenas no
sobre todo por los reproches de mi tía
camelina cuando no la felicité en su
cumpleaños pero es que no había facebook
que me recordara y eso es algo que ella
todavía no entiende o con su mis amigas
se empezaron a aprovechar para empezar a
subir todas las fotos que nunca las dejé
porque no me gustaba como salía y claro
las mil y un fiestas de las que no me
enteré
todo me había resultado tan sencillo
hasta el segundo día que me invitaron a
comer
que me invitaban a comer y de pronto una
serie de movimientos involuntarios por
querer agarrar mi celular desbloquearlo
darme cuenta que no tenía absolutamente
nada que ver y volverlo a bloquear
haciéndome parecer totalmente
desorientada además de lo que vengo
llamando el síndrome de la vibración
ficticia que es cuando tú sientes tu
juras que te vibró el celular o se
iluminó la pantalla y al checarlo nadie
te llama
no hay ninguna notificación nadie quiere
saber de ti evento que me hizo darme
cuenta que tal cual adicción
mi cuerpo comenzaba es acostumbrarse
manifestando una horrible ansiedad
malestar y hasta iluminaciones
al día de hoy me ha dado cuenta que la
era de los medios de comunicación nos
han adentrado en un ciclo de salida
complicadísimo y cada segundo que
pasamos en ellas nos llevan a tres fases
que determine a lo largo de esta
experiencia número uno el sobre pensar
sobre pensar lo que no soy
en vez de enfocarme en lo que soy número
dos comparar con base en lo que no tengo
en vez de apreciar lo que tengo número
tres un sentimiento de insuficiencia e
inconformidad tanto con lo que soy como
con lo que tengo tres fases que se
dirigen en fila india a una única
conclusión las redes sociales nos están
causando infelicidad la falta de
seguridad y amor por lo que somos y lo
que tenemos nos están llevando por la
vida en una bici sin frenos
rápido y sin ninguna dirección optando
siempre por el lugar más cómodo y fácil
de bajarnos de manera que no salgamos
lastimados pero hoy quiero invitarte a
que antes de que tomes el manubrio de tu
vida despegues tanto todo tu vista el
celular y te des el tiempo de conocerte
de identificar tu verdad de dedicarle
esfuerzo a la que sinceramente va a ser
la única relación constante a largo
plazo que vas a tener a lo largo de toda
tu vida
de identificar qué es lo que quieres y
adónde quiere llegar y así poder confiar
que aunque te falten frenos y te vayas a
dar en la torre una y tres mil veces
al levantarte vas a seguir teniendo un
mismo objetivo y las mismas ganas de
llegar a él porque en un mundo de
followers hashtags y reacciones cada vez
es más difícil no distraerte de tu sueño
ya que entramos en confianza ya les dije
mi tiempo en pantalla que les hice
invitaciones y todo el rollo quiero
pedirles un solo aplauso a las
respuestas afirmativas de mis siguientes
preguntas
primero alguna vez te has comparado con
alguien que está a través de una
pantalla
[Aplausos]
segundo ha sentido envidia por alguien o
algo que has visto en las redes sociales
[Aplausos]
tercero lo que ves en instagram twitter
facebook ha sido objeto de chis y
crítica de la madre entre tú y tus
amigos
es ese estuvo fuerte
un último aplauso por las veces que un
tweet o un post animado tu día
completamente
ok creo que si me han escuchado a lo
largo de esta plática ustedes mismos
sabrán identificar mi error unos
momentos atrás las redes sociales no nos
están causando infelicidad señoras y
señores es el uso que le estamos dando a
las redes sociales lo que nos está
haciendo total y desgraciadamente
infelices
creo considero que los firmó que la
mayoría del tiempo volvíamos el
superpoder de estas herramientas de la
comunicación y que éstas como el fuego
las podemos usar para quemar a una
sociedad entera o para calentar un
caldito y alimentarlos
está en ti es tu decisión el dejar de
intentar
impresionada a la gente y el querer
empezar a tratar de impactar en ellos
habiendo dicho esto no me quiero ir hoy
con la idea de que van a salir de aquí a
borrar todas sus aplicaciones nada
mi fin el día de hoy es que se
cuestionen si realmente están listos
para usar las redes sociales cosas que
podemos averiguar ahorita ya que ando
acá arriba
te preocupa más como tu vida se ve antes
que como tu vida se siente
críticas más de lo que hagas
es más si no hubiera internet me pudiera
aventar un like por ahí o una reacción
de seguirías gustando que seguiría
sintiendo suficiente
creo que con base a tus respuestas tú
mismo sabrás determinar si necesitas
desconectar para reconectar como yo sin
postear ni lakers solamente vivir
[Aplausos]